we start with the unfolding humanitarian
crisis in the horn of africa the u.n
says the region is experiencing its
worst drought in four decades and the
problem is compounded by a lack of
humanitarian aid as a result millions
could face farming in parts of ethiopia
kenya somalia and djibouti the ongoing
war in ukraine is further worsening the
already worrying situation
somalia in particular is the worst
affected dw correspondent maria mueller
traveled to the town of dolo where three
camps for internally displaced people
have sprung up in the last few months
15 days of walking through the hot
desert with little water and no food
hercia mohammed left her village with
three children but he arrived with only
one
we were walking and walking my son was
very thirsty and exhausted he asked me
many times mommy water mummy water he
started gasping but there was nothing no
drop of water i could give him
her sick eight-year-old daughter died on
arrival at the camp suffering from a bad
cough and weakened from the journey
as the drought worsens children are
among the most vulnerable the un
protects that if nothing is done 350 000
of the 1.4 million severely malnourished
children could starve to death
at the nearby clinic we meet mothers
waiting for treatment for their
malnourished babies
one of them is ramon novadere when she
lost over a hundred goals due to the
drought she left her village with her
nine children without the support of her
relatives they wouldn't survive she says
two of her children are malnourished
i can't put him down to rest because
he's sick but since last night sweating
and fever have gone down when we lost
our livestock we lost our minds
we can't live without our livestock
like her many of those who fled are
livestock farmers
more than half a million people have
been driven from their homes this year
alone according to the world food
programme
more than six million are now facing
critical hunger
this drought has the face of a child
and not only are children suffering from
malnutrition they are also suffering
from other risks
such as early marriage in the case of
girls
and then being recruited in armed groups
in the case of boys
the islamist militant group al-shabab is
a constant threat in this region
these women have come from a town which
has been under siege by al-shabab for
the last seven years
we were denied from farming our land
blocked from growing our greens the
water access was blocked there was no
access to food either and no cars moving
we left because of that
we came on foot we walked for several
nights we grabbed our children and
walked
away in order to survive people try to
earn money in nearby villages and buy
food with the little they have
inflated prices make the situation even
worse
the prices of food in somalia were
already soaring up because
people's livestock are dying cereal
harvests are way below long-term
averages we are concerned that the war
in ukraine could further exacerbate what
we're already soaring prices in somalia
somalia is heavily dependent on ukraine
and russia for its wheat imports with
the port of odessa and ukraine now
closed the un world food programme is
warning that the conflict could further
drive up food prices we are having to
prioritize to really target those most
in need for immediate life saving but
that means that we are taking from the
hungry to feed the starving
wfp needs 192 million dollars urgently
to avert famine that could hit as early
as mid-year
it's a race against time
let's talk more about this with
francesco regamonte he is the regional
humanitarian coordinator for oxfam in
east and central horn of africa hello
francesco thanks for joining us so
millions in the home of africa
especially in somalia are facing risk of
farming what is the driving force behind
this
thank you very much and thank you for
having me
there are like a number of
drivers for this crisis
conflict
climate change increased creating a risk
of increased drought and floods
the effects of covid we should not
forget that the horn of africa was eat
last year by the worst locust
infestation in years
and of course the increase of prices are
contributing to this to this crisis
so many different factors but who's
affected the most
this crisis unfortunately is very
unequal is affecting part of the of the
countries where where there has been
less investment by the local government
and is affecting women and children just
to give you an idea there are at the
moment in somalia 1.4 million children
that they are malnourished
that's like more than the population of
munich
there are 350 000 people
every children in
in somalia that they are really at risk
of starvation if no intervention is is
taken and is the same in south sudan 1.3
million
children there again more than the
population of munich
and as you see rightfully so an
intervention is needed i understand the
much needed support is being hampered by
the war in ukraine how is that impacting
the crisis in the horn of africa
thank you for this question there are
like a number of
of elements that they are
that they are at play here first of all
is the attention the international
international media attention and the
international donor attention is now
focused on ukraine and is not on the
horn of african and east africa then
there is an effect on food prices
because
russia and ukraine are producer of wheat
and these and this is creating like
this crisis is creating an increase
in in the prices which were already high
before and then the price of oil that is
making our job and the job of our
partners more more expensive and is
driving all the all the cost up and then
there is an issue related to the
the
the price of other items like
fertilizers and
and
those are the effects of of the ukraine
crisis on the situation in east africa
i guess
it's easier to blame the situation in
ukraine but even before the war in
ukraine aid alone has never been enough
to tackle food insecurity in the region
people are dying and many others are
suffering what is needed to solve the
problem
i think it's what is needed is a
concerned effort as you correctly
pointed out aid is not enough
we need to have action at the local
level the local government should put
resources to affect this to address
these prices international communities
should give more and more
if we are talking about like the appeal
the u.n appeal we are talking about four
billion it seems like a big amount of
money but
is not
if it's compared with the money that we
put for kovid or the money that we the
international communities as allocated
to ukraine so it's the political will
that is that is missing and
and we also need like a concerned effort
of all the actors u.n agencies in
international organizations like oxfam
but
also local organization they are on the
front line of this response
okay francesco regamonte with oxfam in
east and central horn of africa thank
you
thank you very much
now it's not just the horn of africa
facing the humanitarian crisis some west
african countries are also struggling to
meet food security demands but the
crisis there is mainly driven by
islamist insurgencies that have forced
millions of people off their land in
countries like burkina faso mali niger
and nigeria many who rely on farming for
their survival are prevented from
accessing it dw's flourish chukura went
to my degree in nigeria to meet one
farmer who's afraid to go back even
though the government says it is safe to
return
abu and his family have found safety
here
seven years ago they ran away from their
home village of baga 200 kilometers from
here when boko haram attacked
thousands were killed among them abu's
brother
boko haram came into baga firing their
guns
we started running but they came after
us
they told my brother to put down his
two-year-old daughter
and then they shot him in the neck
abu now lives in a settlement for
internally displaced people
recently the government said it would
shut down the camps it stopped ngos from
providing aid and sent people back to
their villages even though the danger of
boko haram has not gone away
this is one of the few remaining idp
camps in maiduguri more than 20 000
people who fled boko haram insurgents in
their villages live here and for six
years they've depended on eight
organizations for their food now those
eight organizations are saying they
can't help them anymore
it's really difficult my late brother's
two children my parents my sick older
brothers eight children all depend on me
for food we're really struggling to feed
them
the government says it does not want
people to depend on aid but instead they
should go back to their livelihoods and
farms it gave them some money to restart
their lives and worked to rebuild the
villages the government says they are
safe to return home
despite frequent reports of attacks
we don't relocate people where there is
no peace or no security
if people feel they are not safe to
return to their village or town we give
them a place that is very close to my
degree or somewhere else that is safe so
that these people can start farming
again
this is our intention
many of the displaced say they do want
to go home but only when their safety
can be guaranteed
honestly it's not right the poor are
forced to do whatever the government
tells them
i'm staying here because i don't have a
choice this is not what i want
rights organizations like human rights
watch have criticized the government's
decision calling it unconscionable and
saying it creates risks and hardships
for people who have already lost
everything
without urgent aid hundreds of thousands
of them will not know where their next
meal will come from
this has really brought us a lot of
worries about food
children now have to sell water to earn
the money that allows us to feed them
women go into the bush to fetch firewood
and sell it to get some money for food
it's frightening
with food supplies from aid
organizations halted and no end in sight
to the boko haram insurgency
abu and other displaced people here at
the camp in maduguri can only pray that
things get better
now food security is just one of the
issues affecting africa leaders
recognize the need for more
collaborative solutions to make life
bearable for many on the continent this
week politicians and other decision
makers from africa and europe got
together in berlin for what is called
the africa round table the event
addressed topics including how the war
in ukraine is impacting lives across
africa decision makers at the event
included ahmad
senegal's minister of economy planning
and cooperation ladies and gentlemen
today
and uh it's a pleasure to welcome
minister amado hot uh right here with me
in the studio thank you very much for
coming thank you for inviting me it's a
pleasure to be here very welcome so of
all the issues discussed at the africa
roundtable event what in your opinion
needs urgent attention
uh thank you very much for being here
the round africa roundtable is a great
platform
for political
and business leaders to meet
to discuss pressing issues that are
affecting the continent today but also
to discuss on how we can strengthen the
partnership
between africa
and europe
and for us it was very important uh to
be there uh to
uh insist
uh on the most depressing issues that we
are dealing with today especially after
kovid 19 or we are still managing covet
19 it's not 100 gone
and suddenly we have the ukrainian
crisis
that is affecting everybody around the
world but even more so affecting
africans
let's hammer a bit now on
the war in ukraine which is affecting
many around the world including across
the continent uh there's rising cost of
living fuel and food prices really
increasing
what should african countries do to ease
the burden of citizens
we have short-term
actions that need to be taken
to immediately
reduce the impact on the population
we need to find ways
to reduce
the impact of increase of food price and
oil prices
in many african countries
you need to basically
provide some financial support
for going some tax revenue because when
you import product there are tax custom
duties that need to be paid but some
countries have to
cancel those to avoid the prices
increasing
at the same time also
countries need to really
think medium long term it's not
acceptable that africa that has
vast arable land that has water that has
everything
continues to rely on other countries
for food but that's the case though and
all these things you're saying should be
done it's really not being done by many
african countries and that's the
ordinary person that suffers
and now it's going to be done we won't
have a choice we've seen actually during
the covet 19 crisis several countries
including senegal we have put
food sovereignty but also pharmaceutical
sovereignty at the heart of our recovery
plans
while we are executing those plans the
ukrainian crisis has come
what we are doing right now
a couple of things one is
we are providing some subsidy on food
and it is affecting our budget today
the increase in oil prices increase in
food prices it is costing us an extra
three percent roughly almost three
percent of gdp
that the government has to find from
somewhere to support the poor but what
we are doing also in senegal and some
countries has doing it is to do targeted
cash transfers
four days ago we launched a massive
uh 43 billion cfa which is about a
80 million dollars
initiative to really provide cash to the
poorest families in senegal about
500 or 50 000 families across the
country
that are receiving money from the
government to help them
address the increase in food price to
address some of the bills that they have
now at the africa roundtable event you
touched on it a bit earlier you talked
about a paradigm shift yes uh building a
new eu africa partnership what's wrong
with the current one and how should it
be like the current one is working but
we can do much better africa has many
needs and we need to accelerate africa's
development we cannot wait for 50 years
or 100 years on something that we can do
in 10 15 years if there is a will
whenever there is a will the leadership
uh there is a way we've seen during the
covey times we've been innovative we've
been bald the world raised 20 trillion
dollars only for g20 countries to deal
with covet and for africa's need i think
if people
believe in it and say that in africa
that is prosperous that has a bigger
actually
a middle class
is positive for europe and for the rest
of the world and the ukrainian crisis
has shown that europe needs also to
diversify its source of revenue but also
it needs to diversify the markets where
it's selling its product to that market
is africa we believe over the next years
to come but the market needs today big
investment so that we can create the
wealth and the economic opportunities
for many africans so that tomorrow they
will be the consumers of europe
we've been talking about africa beyond
aid many african leaders have been
talking about that and um
as we all agree there's a difference
between talking it and walking it
what really is needed to achieve the
dream of africa beyond age so that we
will be self-sufficient and self-reliant
enough and not have to go out several
things should be done
domestically we african there are things
we need to do the reforms that we have
started we need to do more of those
reforms in particular on domestic
resource mobilization to generate more
revenue
for the government which means to widen
the tax base not to increase the tax
rate for the people already paying tax
but to make sure that those who don't
pay tax we bring them into the tax
system so this is one but also the
international community has to be also
more i would say proactive when it comes
to africa's issues one example if you
take the rating agencies
for us the ratings that are being
actually assigned to africa
probably are not always reflecting
the real risk on the ground and that has
to change
that has to change amado hots and the
girls minister of economy planning and
cooperation many thanks for your time
thank you very much appreciate it